[Musique]
[Rires]
bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de mode d'emploi avec un focus sur les
métiers du btp
sans oublier notre volet consacré à la
formation sans plus tarder voici le
sommaire entre en bâtiment est maître
d'ouvragé découverte de ces métiers
présents dans le secteur du bâtiment et
des travaux publics et des professions
exercées dans l'entreprise 50 ans
bâtiment à montigny le bretonneux et
aussi au sein de l'agglomération de 50
ans ni pleurs et des métiers du bâtiment
hôtel on peut se former au cfm btp
située à trappes le centre de formation
des métiers du bâtiment et des travaux
publics accueille chaque année près de
200 apprentis
l'établissement propose des formations
en alternance du ceap et au bts
le btp comprenez bâtiment et travaux
publics fait partie des six grands pôles
économiques présents à saint quentin en
yvelines elle la filière fourni plus de
15000 emplois
un secteur dynamique car il faut le dire
les projets ne manquent pas sur notre
territoire
rénovation complète d'un appartement ou
encore réhabilitation d'un édifice
public plusieurs métiers interviennent
pour mener à bien ses missions
reportage
[Musique]
depuis près de 30 ans la société saint
quentin bâtiment intervient pour des
travaux de maçonnerie de plomberie ou
encore de peinture installé à montigny
le bretonneux l'équipe de onze salariés
vient tout juste d'emménager dans de
nouveaux locaux
saint-quentin bâtiment est à peu près à
90% actuellement sur des chantiers de
particuliers entre montigny voisin
guyancourt principalement et nous avons
de plus en plus d'entreprises sur la
ville nouvelle qui font appel à nos
services
un mot sur le secteur du btp alors
évidemment vous connaissez l'adage quand
le bâtiment va tout va
est-ce que c'est d'actualité alors pour
ma société je peux dire qu'effectivement
oui c'est d'actualité
nous avons la chance sur saint quentin
en yvelines d'avoir une clientèle avec
un fort pouvoir d'achat et des gens qui
ont beaucoup de projets beaucoup d'idées
qui se laissent les moyens de ses
ambitions
nous avons même d'ailleurs beaucoup de
mal des fois à fournir car
le nombre d'appels et de demander de
sollicitations et supérieurs à ce que
nous pouvons produire comme chantier
pendant l'année
[Musique]
nous sommes chez un particulier à
montigny le bretonneux la société saint
quentin bâtiment intervient pour la
rénovation complète de cet appartement à
mes côtés jacques ada le gall bonjour
bonjour vous êtes peintre en bâtiment
alors quelle est votre mission sur ce
chantier
alors ces eaux ce chantier ont fait
on refait tout l'appartement donc du sol
au plafond
donc voilà pour l'un aujourd'hui
j'interviens pour faire du rebouchage et
de la peinture alors est ce que tu peux
nous en dire plus sur votre parcours
scolaire
alors j'ai fait un cap2 peintre en
bâtiment en normandie
et puis j'ai eu une petite interruption
d'une cinquante de cinq années où
j'allais dans la restauration et je suis
revenu à mon métier premier à quinze ans
maintenant
là on sent la société vous faites
uniquement de la peinture ou vous faites
autre chose que je fais je fais un petit
peu de tout qu'est ce qui me plaît dans
ce métier c'est la diversité
là je fais de l'enduit demain je peux
aussi bien faire des faux plafonds lundi
je vais faire du carrelage
voilà c'est ya pas de routine depuis peu
la société saint quentin bâtiment
propose de nouveaux services comme la
toiture ou encore l'isolation avec un
million d'euros de chiffre d'affaires à
l'année elle souhaite néanmoins garder
son côté proximité et privilégie les
chantiers au sein de notre territoire
autres métiers présents dans le secteur
du btp maître d'ouvragé
c'est le cas de franck titon depuis 2004
il est directeur adjoint de la
construction et des bâtiments à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines son rôle
définir le cahier des charges et suivre
l'avancement d'un projet de construction
de réhabilitation d'un bâtiment public
exemple le vélodrome nationale ou encore
la gare de saint quentin en yvelines
ça c'est un travail qui a été fait en
2010 et 2011
tout ce travail de conception de
définition de choix des coloris des
matériaux pour aboutir à des travaux qui
ont été faits courant 2012 et 2013
j'ai eu la chance de savoir à ces jeunes
ce que je voulais travailler dans le
bâtiment donc j'ai fait un bac
technologique qui n'existe plus
maintenant qui s'appelle le pack arcade
qui était centré sur le génie civil un
bts conducteur de travaux
et puis ensuite je rentrais dans la vie
active actuellement seront petit on
supervise plusieurs projets de
réhabilitation qui ont pour vocation de
rendre des bâtiments plus économes en
énergie la médiathèque 17 mar ou encore
la médiathèque anatole-france à trappes
sont concernés un métier qui demande de
nombreuses compétences métier de maître
d'ouvragé
j'ai souvent tendance à le comparer à
être chef d'orchestre un peu c'est à
dire qu'il faut que chacun joue sa
partition au bon moment avec la bonne
tonalité pour que l'opération pour que
le projet puisse aboutir en temps et en
heure à une utilisation et à un coût
maîtrisé profession d'encadrement ou
professions manuelles les débouchés dans
le secteur du bâtiment et des travaux
publics sont nombreux à saint quentin en
yvelines et pourra prendre ces métiers
il existe un large panel de formations
nous avons justement pousser les portes
du cfm dtp à trappes
l'établissement propose plusieurs
spécialités en alternance qui vont du
ceap et au bts en passant par le bac
professionnel
reportage
[Musique]
le centre de formation des métiers du
bâtiment et des travaux publics existe
depuis plus de 40 ans dans les yvelines
mais c'est en 2005 qu'il s'est implanté
ici dans la zone de trappes et l'encours
des formations qui permettent
l'apprentissage de métiers diversifiés
comme peintre coureurs ou encore
constructeur de boutiques
nous sommes affiliés à trois fédérations
la fédération du bâtiment la fédération
des travaux publics et à la chambre
nationale syndicale de l'étanchéité
à partir de là il peut faire des métiers
qu'on va voir avec l'étanchéité les
travaux publics et le bâtiment lors dans
le bâtiment fera entendre la peinture la
maçonnerie et la maintenance des
bâtiments et des collectivités alors
quels types de diplômes les apprentis
peuvent peuvent avoir l'issue de leur
formation
alors on a un panel de diplômes que ces
vastes ça va s'appeler première année
jusqu'au bts tp deuxième année quelles
sont les qualités indispensables en fait
pour pouvoir intégrer ce type de
pharmaciens ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que les apprentis qu'on a ici c'est
avant tout des salariés d'entreprises en
tant que salariés d'entreprises ils ont
des devoirs et des obligations qui sont
semblables aux nôtres
à partir de là il faut avoir des
qualités d'acidité il faut être
courageux pour avoir envie de travailler
on a des d'étudiants qui sont avec une
certaine pénibilité mais faut pas avoir
peur de travailler vraiment motivés à
aller de l'avant
[Musique]
certes dur bonjour bonjour alors on se
trouve dans la salle de travaux
pratiques pour la formation gros oeuvre
est ce qu'on peut nous en dire plus sur
cette formation de son entreprise ou
deux semaines à l'école est souvent
jongle entre ateliers ou classe et à ce
moment on fait
et un peu de tout alors pourquoi vous
avez choisi cette formation
j'adore surtout travailler en équipe et
et monter enfin quand j'ai fini de faire
mon travail et que je reviens plus tard
sur mon sur ce que j'ai fait est fière
d'eux
d'avoir de vous regarder ce que moi même
j'ai fait de me dire j'ai réussi et les
gens ils passent devant et ils sont
contents
[Musique]
gagner bonjour vous êtes en train de
régler un appareil de nivellement c'est
dans le cadre de votre formation à
travaux publics alors vous vous êtes ans
en 2e année bts et ce qu'il faut dire
c'est que vous avez un parcours un peu
atypique on va dire est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire plus
oui moi j'ai commencé en faisant des
études d'assistante manager est en fait
je les ai fait en alternance à la sncf
et c'est là où j'ai découvert donc le
monde des travaux et par la suite du
coup j'ai décidé de me réorienter dans
les travaux publics
avec cette nouvelle formation alors
qu'est ce qui vous plaît dans cette dans
cette formation est basse et le fait de
ne pas calculer ces journées elles sont
toutes différentes ont travaillé baisse
du coût en extérieur comme aujourd'hui
voilà le fait d'être constamment en
déplacement d'accord il à paris n'est
gelé tout ce sont aujourd'hui c'est par
un frein justement à vous dire je vais
devoir travailler comme ça dehors ça
fait partie des aléas des aléas du
métier mais aussi habituer
c'est vrai qu'on pourrait s'imaginer que
c'est difficile et puis finalement je
trouve qu'on est très bien acceptée et
au contraire les hommes vont être plutôt
attentionné et vont nous aider donc moi
j'ai eu aucun souci
[Musique]
d
le cfm btp attrape accueille
actuellement 200 apprentis
un chiffre qui pourrait doubler ces
prochaines années avec de grands
chantiers attendus dans notre région est
des métiers du btp qui offre de nombreux
débouchés mais pour lesquels vous l'avez
vu et bien il est elle nécessaire
d'avoir une formation adéquate
je vous propose de revenir en détail
justement sur 2 métiers tout d'abord le
métier de peintre en bâtiment qui
exercent jacques alain le gall au sein
de l'entreprise saint quentin bâtiment
alors pour cela il faut obtenir un ca
paix ou un brevet professionnel peintre
pour le salaire compte et 1750 euros net
après 10 ans d'expérience environ
possibilités d'évolution chef de
chantier
le petit plus dans ce métier savoir être
multitâche deuxième profession et
directeur adjoint de la construction et
des bâtiments pour une collectivité ou
une agglomération tels que saint quentin
en yvelines comme vous avez pu le voir
dans le reportage concernant la
formation il faut obtenir un bts
conducteur de travaux pour la
rémunération compter environ 3400 euros
net après 20 ans d'expérience
possibilités d'évolution directeur de la
construction et des bâtiments enfin le
petit plus dans ce métier aimez le
travail en équipe
voilà vous en savez désormais plus sur
les métiers du btp
pour rappel sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines c'est un secteur qui
recrute
voilà c'est bientôt la fin de ce mode
d'emploi mais avant comme à chaque fois
nous allons faire le tour des rendez
vous qui vous attendent
mercredi 13 décembre le ski cube à
guyancourt organise un atelier intitulé
un micro entreprenariat lancer votre
activité
c'est de 9h30 à 11h30 c'est gratuit mais
il faut s'inscrire sur le site
www.skype.com si vous voulez maintenant
savoir plus sur les métiers de la petite
enfance et de l'animation
et bien sachez que la cité des métiers
attrape propose une réunion sur ce thème
elle se déroulera jeudi 14 décembre de
14h à 17h30
inscription obligatoire au 01 34 82 82
enfin le pôle emploi de guyancourt
organise une grande session de
recrutement dans le domaine
de la restauration 20 postes sont à
pourvoir la session se déroulera le 19
décembre mais il faut auparavant
envoyez votre cv à l'adresse qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran ape
points 60 18 121 @ paul tirer emploi.fr
voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi à 19
décembre pour un nouveau mode d'emploi
ont consacré cette fois ci aux métiers
des services à la personne
à très bientôt
[Musique]
[Rires]